après le premier le premier acte subi je
suis rentré chez moi et j'ai pleuré pour
la dernière info façon miroir
j'avais 11 ans et demi donc c'est là où
je suis mort émotionnellement
[Musique]
comme toute victime j'étais dans un
sentiment de honte de culpabilité
j'ai pas parlé la première fois après
jeu j'étais piégé en fait j'étais pris
dans l'engrenage et il a su en profiter
il avait vraiment l'avait remise sur moi
puisque le jour où j'ai fait ma première
avec une fille je suis la première
personne à qui je suis allé le dire et
penser qu'il allait me laisser
tranquille et au contraire saluer les
faits aggravants puisqu'il a multiplié
ses actes et qui devenait de plus en
plus violents sur moi j'étais jeune
j'étais sa chose j'étais sombre j'ai
appris pendant le procès qu'il était
amoureux de moi j'ai pas parlé avant
tout simplement parce que perdre pas
être cru puisqu'il était tellement
apprécié de tout le monde de tout le
village de toute la famille que j'avais
peur qu'on me disais c'est pas possible
que ce type là soit 6 à 2 face à ça tu
doit inventer
g j'avais mis en place un mécanisme
d'autodestruction qui était en premier
la violence où j'étais devenu très
violent sur le terrain et après en
dehors il y avait de l'alcool quand on
sortait mais on était sans limites quand
on est victime n'est pas borderline dans
les jusqu'au boutistes donc on buvait
jusqu'à ce que tend le partage quasiment
le sexe ont multiplié les conquêtes
l'argent j'ai dû me faire dernier de
casino parce que là aussi je n'avais pas
de limite donc j'ai été je claquais tout
l'argent que j'avais même celui que je
n'avais pas j'étais conscient de tout ce
que je faisais en 1e tour quand je
trempais mes compagnes camp quand je me
battais tout je savais d'où venait le
mal d'où venaient ces envie de faire
n'importe quoi parce qu'on nous vole
notre personnalité et après d âpres et
c'est ça qu'on a envie de se la
réapproprier d'exister donc se mettre en
avant
il y en a qui vont être introverti moi
j'étais au contraire il fallait que
j'existe aux yeux des autres
[Musique]
la première personne à qui j'en ai parlé
c'est mon ex femme corinne qui justement
avait voulu éviter mathieu la première
victime à mon anniversaire vous faire la
surprise et d'inviter mathieu ça faisait
dix ans que je l'avais pas vu et il
l'avait dit ok je viens l'anniversaire
de ses basques une condition c'est que
cricket ne soit pas là elle était étonné
puisque l'ouverture elle était il était
très apprécié donc librement pourquoi
que si tu as fait bénin violet et dans
le soir quand je rentre du boulot je me
dis ah si toi parce que j'ai quelque
chose d'important à se dire on venait de
se marier je n'y vois tu veux pas dire
c'est quand j'ai déjà toujours avec un
peu de country dans l'air est en fait un
résident c'est beaucoup plus grave
je vais te faire la surprise était
invité mathieu attendent anniversaire
avec une condition que cricket ne soit
pas là et là je n'ai tourné jeudi matin
ça fait dix ans que je n'ai pas vu il
met ses conditions en plus pour venir
mon anniversaire en fait c'est chier
quoi et milan mais en fait il a violé et
l'a vu que j'étais sans réaction sur le
coup j'ai rien dit mais j'ai les épaules
qui sont tombés je me suis liquéfiée
dans le dans le canapé et je me suis je
vais quand même pouvoir parler je ne
suis pas seul en fait au départ quand
j'ai parlé j'étais pas dans l'objectif
de porter plainte immédiatement après
mon anniversaire j'ai souhaité quand
même que ce samedi soir je fais de mes
30 ans et ma famille et le lendemain par
contre je vous avait convoqué pour leur
expliquer ce qu'est ce qui m'est arrivé
je leur explique que ce que j'ai subi et
là j'ai commencé à entendre les
réflexions comme mais tu as quand même
pas porté plainte pour le monde la
famille datant du 20 ans pour parler que
tu parle maintenant
le mieux
ce qui est arrivé le 29 mai 2013 avec
cet égard ses rations pour dix ans cette
sentence et qui est tombé a été
révélatrice a été libératrice
[Musique]
j'interviens beaucoup dans le milieu
sportif mais de plus en plus dans
l'éducatif dans les écoles primaires va
partir c'est met en scène deux dans les
collèges les lycées dans les creps aussi
le constat est accablant de l'année
dernière avec la saône a fait 300
interventions c'est minimum de victimes
d'agressions sexuelles qui ont été
révélés suite à ses interventions
donc ça représente au minimum 600
personnes je suis la preuve qu'on peut
s'en sortir mais pour ça il faut parler
la honte doit changer de camp
on n'est pas coupable on est victimes
donc il faut parler un professionnel il
faut parler à une colosse il faut parler
un psychologue
il faut parler à sa personne de
confiance si on ne peut pas parler il
faut écrire ce qui est écrit n'est plus
dans l'esprit si vous avez un copain ou
une copine qui se scarifie par exemple
ou qui vous laisse ce secret qui la rend
malheureuse ou malheureux il faut pas
avoir peur de le partager un secret qui
doivent être partagées comme les
professionnels doivent le faire il faut
partager des secrets pour éviter
justement que ces personnes avaient haye
est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus loin
dans la destruction et peut-être fatale
malheureusement pour elle